[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
Hi we're here
at dotJS, an amazing
place and I'm here
with Addy Osmani, who
was on stage minutes
ago talking about
a lot of things.
You managed to cram, you know--
ADDY OSMANI: I crammed
in all the things.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE: Yeah.
So how about we talk
about maybe Yeoman.
And you talk about Yeoman
being part of those three tools
that you think are
important, not just
because developers
are lazy, because they
want to be more productive.
So can you maybe
set the stage here.
ADDY OSMANI: Sure.
So Yeoman is a project we've
been working on for a year.
It's sort of this workflow
for the front end,
for helping developers
stay really productive.
And it gives them
three things and we
think are really compelling
for you to stay efficient.
The first is a tool
called yo, which
is really useful
for scaffolding.
So let's say you're trying to
create a new AngularJS app,
or something using
Ember or Backbone.
Rather than having to go
looking for the boilerplate
for that app, and trying to fit
a workflow of tools around it
that works well for you, we can
actually give you all of that
just by running one command.
So it saves you time
and it gets you up
and running much quicker.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE: OK.
ADDY OSMANI: We've also
got in that workflow,
we've also got Grunts, which
is a really great task runner,
gives you a really great build
process, and Bower, which
is really useful for
managing dependencies.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
So Yeoman and yo
is really co-generator,
and those are mostly
known for one chaw
generation, and then
you kind of need to re-run it,
and you start from scratch,
and how does that work?
Is there any
incremental side to it?
ADDY OSMANI: Yes, so we
thought a lot about how
we can improve iterative
development as well.
And so Yeoman also comes with
a concept of sub generators.
And the idea is,
let's say you're
trying to scaffold out a
smaller piece of your app.
It might be a view, or a
router, or a new component.
You can run commands
that will actually
let you do that on top of
the initial set of things
that you've scaffolded out.
So you can continuously
keep using the tool
whenever you want to create
something new, regardless
of how large or how small it is.
So the best place to find
out information about Yeoman
is Yeoman.io.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE: OK.
ADDY OSMANI: But the
community around the project
has been growing pretty
rapidly over the past year.
There isn't a day that goes by
where I haven't seen someone
trying to create something
new with the project.
And we've got a whole
ecosystem of generators
now whereby, if in most cases
you pick out a framework
you want to use-- and not just
if it's a JavaScript framework,
but in many cases it could
be a mobile framework or even
a back end server
language-- there
are people that everyone
generators to scaffold you
up projects using those.
Probably the most
surprising for me
was one of our most
popular generators
is actually one for
WordPress Project.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
Interesting.
ADDY OSMANI: Something we
hadn't considered at all
but people are using it
for whatever's useful.
ALEXIS
MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE: So you
mentioned mobile, does Yeoman
do anything specific for mobile?
ADDY OSMANI: Yes actually.
So our team spent a month
doing a lot of mobile web
development, just to
get a really good feel
for the current
landscape of tools
that developers have to use.
And on the back of
that, we put together
a Yeoman generator
called generator-mobile.
And what that gives
you out of the box
is a really great boilerplate
for creating mobile web apps.
It's fast.
It's very small.
But we also give you a
whole set up of tools
for testing in the cloud,
local device testing,
on getting a live
iterative workflow
across multiple
devices at one time.
So edit on your
desktop, refreshes
across all of your devices.
And it just makes it
a little bit easier
when you're trying
to create something
that works great on mobile.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
Awesome.
So another big part
of your talk was
about Web Components and
Polymer, the Polymer Project.
So tell us a little
bit how that plays
versus existing standards
that are being developed.
Should people
consider this today,
or is it just so they
know, and then start
using it maybe once it's ready?
ADDY OSMANI: So I think Polymer
is a really great solution
to be aware of.
One of the fantastic things
in recent years about sort
of standards bodies
is that they've
been paying a keen eye on
what developers are using.
So like things like data
binding is something
that you tend to
use a JavaScript
framework for a lot
of time these days.
And wouldn't it be fantastic
if something like that
was actually in the platform?
Templating, another thing,
being able to create
sort of components with
proper encapsulation.
We've had to hack
around the platform
to get these features
in place whenever
we're trying to
create large apps.
And finally, through
Web Components,
we're getting some of those.
We're getting a
proper template tag.
We're getting imports that
allow you to package together
different pieces of your app
and let the people use them.
Custom Elements, Shadow
DOM for encapsulation,
lots of really
exciting pieces that
are coming to the platform.
I know a lot of developers
will be wondering,
is this stuff just
landing in Chrome?
And thankfully, no it's not.
We've been talking to
Firefox a lot lately,
and it's actually
looking like they're
going to ship most of the
features needed for web
components directly with Firefox
nightlies in the next couple
weeks.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE: Nice.
ADDY OSMANI: Should be exciting.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
Very nice.
So Polymer is more than
just implementation
of those standards in the word?
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah, so--
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
Is it a UI component library?
Is it a framework?
Is it all of the above?
ADDY OSMANI: It's sort
of all of the above.
It's an ambitious
project, but it's
solving lots of
interesting problems.
Like so consider it
built on top of layers.
The first layer is
polyfills for the platform.
So if you're trying to target
users using a modern browser,
Polymer will work
great in all those.
And with the platform
layer, you'll
be able to work with any of
the standard features that
are being implemented
in browsers.
On top of that, it
has sugaring layer,
which takes away even
more of the boilerplate
that you'd have to use.
If you were authoring just using
regular old web components.
And I've personally
found it really,
really nice for writing pretty
interactive apps without having
to write a lot of code.
And because it's built
in such a way that
encourages code reuse,
and element reuse,
you'll often find that there are
smaller things that you don't
need to go re-implant yourself.
Like the app I was showing on
stage was sort of a YouTube app
for helping you manage
playlists and stuff like that.
And when I was
developing that, I
found that there are some
really nice elements that
helped you do things like
YouTube search, or displaying
YouTube videos, and so on.
And tying those all
together using Polymer
and Web Components was
actually pretty easy.
So I think it's a great
thing to keep an eye on.
Production wise I would
say that we're probably
at least a little while off--
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE: OK.
ADDY OSMANI: But it's still
something to be aware of.
As soon as these things are in
the platform, they're faster,
they're easier to use.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
And for those people
interested in checking
it out, that actually
plays well with Yeoman.
ADDY OSMANI: Yes, yes it does.
There's actually a
generator for Yeoman
that lets you scaffold up
Polymer apps and Polymer
elements as well.
So if people want to
check that, that's
called generator-polymer.
ALEXIS
MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE: Great.
Well I think that's all
the time we have for.
So I'd like to thank you Addy
for answering my questions.
And wishing everyone
great time, and I
hope to see you for
the dot conferences.
Cheers.
ADDY OSMANI: Cheers.
[MUSIC PLAYING]